je peux vous dire dans les scoops c'est
que j'avais reçues afida turner dans mon
bureau avec vous qui connaissez du monde
les gars là c'est moi tournage et
pendant tour pendant qu'elle est dans
mon bureau à 6,2 moi je vois le
téléphone qui sonne michel polnareff et
je pensais que c'était une blague à la
miss a alors que c'était leur martin
hibou on me dit dans l'oreillette que
tina turner ne se rappelle absolument
pas vous avoir rencontré aussi le scoop
tout le monde s'était moqué nous mais je
vous confirme oui j'ai appuyé sur haut
parleur et je lui ai parlé c'est
vraiment michel pinard et non et vous
savez pourquoi
pourquoi mais parce qu'ils étaient
ensemble au belge
ohlala
t'es pas sérieux alors c'est vrai photo
mathieu kauffmann
il était très sûr de soi dans cette
émission qui est enregistrée parce que
ça va m'agacer il aurait été ensemble
tout ça est autorisée est souvent si on
serait elle à los angeles achèterait ami
ok on avance et on continue avec qu'avec
avec catherine on apprend des choses à
catherine oui moi c'est une nouvelle qui
concerne le musée grévin
oui figurez vous que vous y allez j'ai
cru que c'était moi il annonce l'arrivée
d'une grande journaliste j'étais super
content est après j'ai cru que c'était
myriam à jeudi voire sept mejia blessés
d'annoncer les salamé qui rentre au
musée grévin et surtout si vous avez
passé qui virent 2 ancien journaliste
christine ockrent et anne sinclair
ces mêmes journalistes au musée grévin
et ça vous ne saviez pas annoncé les
états n'ont pas tous en même temps
maintenant et sont déjà en tirant mais
non c'est non mais quand on sort un
couteau mais quand on voit là parce que
je regardais beaucoup
non mais la statue de christine ockrent
elle était vraiment cantal et des 40 ans
d'allaiter plus de qualité pour deux
raisons d'abord j'adore d'années mort au
deuxième
on va tous désirent donc sert à nager
avant d'être contenter des anomalies ont
un certain âge mais c'est de laisser la
photo et voilà